[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur wahl des militär
des jahres schön dass sie wieder mit
dabei sind wir zeichnen angehörige des
österreichischen bundesheeres aus die
besonderes geleistet haben und zwar in
den kategorien rekrut des jahres
zivilbedienstete des jahres einheit des
jahres und soldat des jahres außerdem
werden zwei special awards vergeben
heute in dieser folge zeichnen wir den
zivilbediensteten des jahres aus hier
kommt nun eine übersicht der nominierten
in alphabetischer reihenfolge
nominiert als zivildienstersatz des
jahres sind robert fritzenwenger er hat
bei der weiterentwicklung des
sogenannten dynamisch gesicherten
militär netzes und der damit verbundenen
implementierung von sonder netzen
maßgeblich zur digitalisierung und
modernisierung des österreichischen
bundesheeres beigetragen günther prämie
ist seit ausbruch der kreditkrise
hauptakteur bei der versorgung mit
sanitäts gütern er ist eine
schlüsselperson beim aufbau des
strategischen krisen lagers der republik
österreich
rainer regler ist ein ausgewiesener
experte im gefahrengut und munitions
wesen auch international ist er auf
seinem fachgebiet ein gefragter mann das
beweisen seine internationalen einsätze
etwa im senegal oder in mali
wer zivilbedienstete des jahres wird das
verrät uns nun generalmajor andreas
pernsteiner
guten tag sehr geehrte damen und herren
ich freue mich sehr ihnen den
zivilbediensteten des jahres 2021
vorstellen zu dürfen
die coop 19 pandemie hat uns alle war
sehr große herausforderungen gestellt
das österreichische bundesheer leistet
mit seinen mitarbeitern einen
wesentlichen beitrag zur bekämpfung der
pandemie und ist mit seinen einheiten
seit vielen monaten bei umfangreichen
assistenzleistungen im einsatz
damit zum wohl unserer bevölkerung alles
bestmöglich abläuft bedarf es eines
ausgeklügelten
logistischen systems damit sämtliche
benötigten sanitäts güter zur richtigen
zeit in ausreichender anzahl am
richtigen ort sind
dies geschieht durch das österreichische
bundesheer im zusammenwirken mit dem
bundesministerium für soziales
gesundheit pflege und konsumentenschutz
dem roten kreuz den bundesländern und
zahlreichen zulieferfirmen eine
hauptperson dabei ist amtsdirektor
günther priebe er hat seit ausbruch der
pandemie mit enormen fleiß sowie
persönlichem einsatz
die versorgung des bundesheeres und auch
der republik österreich mit sanitäts
gütern sichergestellt
amtsdirektor kriebel war und ist auch
wesentlich beim aufbau des strategischen
krisen lagers beteiligt sein
umfangreiches fachwissen dass sie auch
als gastlehrer an der heeres logistik
schule weitergibt verbunden mit einem
weitgehenden verzicht auf freizeit
stellt die grundlage für eine äußerst
erfolgreiche
sanitäts logistische arbeit ich darf ein
amtsdirektor günther riebel sehr
herzlich zur auszeichnung
zivilbedienstete des jahres 2021
gratulieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
amtsdirektor freiwillig gebe ich ihnen
gerne im namen der mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter
die ehrenauszeichnung zivilbedienstete
des jahres
[Applaus]
ich liebe diese der des jahres 20 21
günther priebe geboren am 15 mai 1984 in
wien seit 1999 ist als
vertragsbedienstete
verteidigungsministerium tätig wer ihn
in seinem büro besucht will etwas ganz
bestimmtes jemand der zu mir ins büro
kommen will
wahrscheinlich versorgungsgüter jene
welche im sanitätsbereich angesiedelt
sind das ist von der injektion
angefangen ich würde ihn vor über
diverse es verbrauchsmaterial in den
sanitäts war es nur in den apotheken
also alles was man in irgendeiner art
und weise benötigt um jemanden zu
versorgen
sanitätsdienstlich und da liegt es nahe
dass seit ausbruch der kogit pandemie er
und seine mitarbeiterinnen so viel zu
tun haben wie nie zuvor kann in der
rechten weise die letzten anhänger waren
wohl tatsächlich freude und leid beim
namen her das ist es total schwierig
gelegentlich vor seid wirklich über die
maßen beanspruchen allerdings muss man
sagen man macht sich für den guten zweck
nicht man schaut dass unsere eigenen
bediensteten soldaten versorgt sondern
mit entsprechenden mit entsprechenden
gütern und auch die republik österreich
nicht und was gibt es in größerer
ansporn in wirklichkeit als wir deshalb
zur arbeit nicht für das wohl der
mitarbeiter um dort die bevölkerung eine
verantwortung die günter baby gelehrt
hat in anderen größenordnungen zu denken
die dimension lässt sich relativ schwer
darstellen in den tatsächlichen zahlen
das variiert manche dinge werden
manchmal zentral bewirtschaftet manche
wären dann wieder dezentral
bewirtschaftet das ist je nach marktlage
im markt verfügbarkeit differenziertes
aber es sei schon doch einige tausend
verschiedene versorgungsgüter in den
jeweiligen stücken sein wie man bei
solchen zahlen ein chaos verhindert
erklärt er so dass mit dem
entsprechenden führungsbereich
so durchgeführt worden wäre dann wäre es
vielleicht ein chaos geworden so war es
immer kontrolliert er aufgrund grund
entsprechenden ankäufen unserer unsere
vorgesetzten hat das ist unnötig wäre
das nicht möglich sein in so einem
einsatz zu koordinieren zu arbeiten so
anstrengend und stressig die kopie zeit
auch ist brille nimmt trotzdem etwas
positives aus ihr mit mehr ruhe zu
bewahren
also für mich persönlich holt so wir
waren nicht eine zenit reißen zu lassen
von dem von dem von dem stress der
anhörung stattfindet versuchen ruhig zu
bleiben das differenziert zu sehen nicht
alles persönlich zu nehmen
manchmal bei belastungsspitzen dann
sagst dann vielleicht doch auch
das ist aber nie persönlich oder böse
gemeinsam im team dachte nur an der
stelle kommunikations weitergabe dass
das passiert und da ist es für mich
extrem beispiel sind dass es ok ruhig
bleiben und versuchen auch die ruhe an
meine mitarbeiter weiterzugeben weil
vielleicht natürlich genauso unter so
einer situation und werden genauso
beansprucht worden worauf sich der
zivilbedienstete des jahres jetzt wieder
richtig frei tja freizeithof und
richtung wieder mehr nein wir haben ein
haus und garten her dass es mit worten
mensch und versuchte sehr viel freizeit
investieren
zu erklären mit mit den händen in der
erde arbeiten ja dass er ein bisschen
draussen auf der luft zu sein also dass
irgendwo mal ausgleichen herzlichen
glückwunsch günther riebel zur
auszeichnung zivilbedienstete des jahres
in der nächsten folge vergeben wir zwei
flächen erwartet ich freue mich wenn sie
wieder mit dabei sind
[Musik]